As we discussed earlier in this lesson, a data
scientist needs to have substantive expertise. What does that mean?
Well typically it means that a data scientist knows
which questions to ask, can interpret the data well and
understands the structure of the data. You can imagine
that a data scientist needs to know about the problem
that solving. For example, if you are solving an
on-line advertising problem, you want to make sure you understand what
types of people are coming to your website. How they are
interacting with the website and what different data means that can
help you ask the right questions like, Are people falling off
and not completing our ads at a certain point in the
flow, or do people complete more ads at a certain time
of the day? You would also, then, be very familiar with
how the data is stored and structured. And that could help
you work more efficiently and more effectively. This is why it's important
for a data scientist to have substantive expertise. It's
important to note that data scientists usually work in
teams. So it's normal for data scientists to be
stronger in some areas and weaker in others. So even
if you, as a data scientist, don't have a
tons of substantive expertise, if you have great hacking
skills or know a lot of statistics you can
still be a valuable member of a data science team.